xavier amodeo arrive à notre rencontre à
vélo le jeune italo haïtien de 20 ans
prend les événements qui ont mené à son
arrestation avec philosophie sa vie de
militant commence à peine et déjà son
visage est reconnue à la suite de la
vidéo / radio canada je vais pas mener
s'arrêter puisque j'ai rien fait de mal
mais je vais juste faire un signe de
paix jafar paix je veux dire je vais
exprimer le fait que j'ai pas
l'intention négative lors de la
manifestation anti capitaliste de
vendredi dernier
xavier a fait l'objet d'une arrestation
musclée par trois agents du spvm et
trois coups portés à la hauteur du
visage du manifestants ont soulevé
l'indignation du public et surtout du
milieu militant j'étais extrêmement
stressé il y avait des policiers qui
m'entouraient je sais pas si on me dit
quelque chose de beau si j'ai dit
quelque chose je pourrais je sais un
pénible dans lanaudière
la mère du jeune militant a dénoncé
l'arrestation hier quand j'ai regardé la
vidéo ma réaction
malgré l'émotion elle reconnaît que le
travail des policiers est souvent
difficile
je suis pour la loi est l'objet
actuellement raconte j'ai rien contre le
travail des policiers
je pense que peut-être une façon de le
faire si monfils s'était opposé de façon
extrême qui a usé de violence j'aurais
pu comprendre qu'on le maintienne qu'on
le maîtrise qu'on la rai j'ai aucun
problème
ce qui me dérange la force abusif le
spvm a commencé son enquête interne pour
élucider les faits entourant les six
d'or captée sur vidéo il manifesté à
plusieurs reprises dans la valise et
quitter s'est assis sur le trottoir a
dit venez m'arrêter à résister je sais
pas de justifier l'intervention des
policiers pourquoi à ce moment sur les
progrès de vous dire qu'on est heureux
avec la façon que ça c'est fait
les policiers souhaitent maintenant
rencontrer le jeune manifestant
personne pour recueillir sa version des
faits ici pascal robidas rage au canada
montréal